this album has really been a labor of
love for you perfecting it for a while
how does it feel to have it out to the
world now
um it's crazy thank you for having me uh
so much it's it's a blessing just to
getting to talk to people about it but
um i waited a year for this album to
come out so i expected a lot you know
of different feelings but i never
expected it to happen to go like this
and it's just such a blessing
um seeing the response i've gotten and
i'm really excited to perform it
on tour with kels because i think it's
gonna change everything even more
i love that how would you describe the
journey for fans and what kind of
journey they'll go on with
tell me about tomorrow it's funny
because it feels nostalgic
you know for those who have roots in
punk it feels brand new for those who
have never really heard it
so i think it does both for a lot of
different people but at the end of the
day it's just really
an album of like hope you know like
i really think that it gets hope to
people or it gives people
faith in different ways um faith in punk
music faith in something bigger
faith in that there's a better tomorrow
you know whatever it may be
i generally make music for like my fans
and uh because i know
that because a juice world was so
vulnerable that's why i was able to
connect with him and it
and it made me realize like my purpose
you know so i just want to do as much as
i can to
try to do that for people i love that
the album cover is that you in the
bathtub and did you always have a dream
of being an artist
uh that is me in the bathtub and um you
know i always knew i was gonna be
something i don't know if i always
thought i was gonna be
a singer but when i was five um
and i was in preschool with you know you
like graduate and stuff but we actually
have it
like on a piece of paper like they asked
me what i wanted to be and i said uh
rockstar a preacher and artist so it
came
so you're all of those things yeah
we'll see what happens in the future
with the other two but you know right
now
i'm definitely a rock star so it's like
i don't know
those are the cool things that you can't
really fight in life you know and it
seems like it's just meant to be
so i take it as destiny that's great how
have your
family and your friends reacted to
everything that's been going on for you
so far
i think that i've actually had a lot of
really uh sweet support from my friends
um you know it you find out who your
real friends are over time
yeah yeah but uh from on a shallow level
all of my
all the people that know me are i've
been super supportive
the people close to me um and that i
like trust
really have been amazing and have done
more for me than anything my family
uh it's been it's been a a crazy road my
sisters and my mom have
been so loving and like helpful towards
me my mom's here right now actually so
it's just been a blessing knowing i have
people that are on my side no matter
what you know
shout out to mom energy that's going to
be good for you moving forward for sure
that's true yeah now you actually
released this album via travis barker's
label
how did that relationship form and what
was it like getting the call
uh you know to get travis to work with
you
i didn't like i knew who travis was at
this point and i also knew who blake was
but i
it was funny that i ended up going with
travis because it was solely based off
of like my interaction with him not
necessarily who he was
because i understood it but because i
was so new to music
and knew that it wasn't like it even is
now like if i knew now
and i was in the same position and i had
travis offered me
you know uh to sign me and every other
label the same way
like i wouldn't even meet with everybody
you know like that's how
that's how it is now but at the time
like i was super like
unaware of everything and so it was
february 26th and the day after
landon like showed travis to tick-tock
it was like yo this kid's making rock
music
and travis like oh and uh so he called
my management team
and um that next day he was like
well that day he was like i want i'm
interested in signing genuine like i'm
gonna work with him
um the next day every single label in
america like
hit us up and was like yo we want to
sign this kid
and it was because the notoriety like
travis springs so
um that's really kind of how it all
started i didn't meet with him for like
two weeks and i finally met with him at
his vegan restaurant he was just like
the most down-to-earth dude
um really like it was it was really like
a gut thing
you know like because he wasn't trying
to put on a show we we had like a
conversation
um but we were just like he was just
real
you know it's better that it happened
that way because
all the stuff that you know him for him
being famous for is great
but at the end of the day to be able to
have that kind of relationship that
working relationship that's what will
give you guys that longevity right
absolutely and um it's really just grown
into like a really really good
relationship
um like work-wise and um
personally you know and it really is
like family to me
um he does so much for me so i love that
dude
and uh it's just it's been the the
greatest journey
so far there's a lot going on in his
life should he get engaged do you have
the perfect wedding gift for him yes
maybe i have a couple i'm sure i could
think of he's like mad funny with gibs
he loves giving gifts he's like i'm the
same way
um but he's better at it than i am so
i'm trying to learn
um i dude i'd love for him to i
genuinely like i i see him at courtney i
think they're amazing
um but like he's just genuinely super
happy you know
um with everything he's doing like you
know his relationships his work
um with me hopefully you know
and it's just been a blessing to see it
happen like i actually have just a lot
of fun with it
like i do i love that back to the music
you said angels and demons is about the
highest highs and the lowest lows
of life um where are you at right now
would you say
i'd say like i met one of the highest
i've ever been
right in my life um but
sometimes like that can be perceived as
like a low
for because it's lonely at the top you
know what i mean and uh
as we as you like start to achieve your
dreams more and more you start to
realize
more things and um i'd say that i'm
the best i've been in a really really
long time but i'm still not really
where i want to be like mentally and
stuff like that
so um i'm really grateful for the
journey
um but i i'm definitely the happiest
i've ever been right now which is really
good that's good
you've also collaborated with machine
gun kelly on wannabe what was that like
oh i mean he's a genius like
kelos is like a genius um i'm really
excited
about to make more music with him just
because like
you make one song and it's just never
enough you know
like i i mean like i have i have a song
with ian and i remember like
two weeks after that came out i was like
we need another song you know and i
we still haven't made one but um i'm
ready just to make more he
he taught me a lot about music taught me
a lot during the music video
and overall he's just a good dude so i'm
ready
where would you like to see yourself
like five to ten years down the road i
mean you're on
a quantum speed right now things are
really happening for you
are you the guy who thinks about five
years ahead of time like where would you
like to be
oh i'm the guy that thinks about uh my
entire life like i
i don't stop like thinking about the
future um it's like even
uh something that i struggle with mental
health is like i like
overthink everything like everything so
i i don't know
that's the problem though is like when
you think so it never goes how you think
that's one thing i've learned is like
you could plan in your head like i have
for so long
um but it never goes exactly how you
think it in five
to ten years i want to be directing
movies
um oh yeah yeah i would
i want to do that um different types of
film you know
also i i always want to make music i
think that
anybody can always do that you know that
like um
i want to produce i think that would be
fantastic
and then also i i i'd like to start a
church in like five to ten years i think
it'd be awesome i think uh
i've i've learned a lot of like um
ways that people have learned how to
twist certain stuff i think that
christianity
right now isn't really at its best
position um and i have a lot of faith
and i just love
love loving people you know i just want
to do things in the future that like
benefit other people's lives and so i
think that
uh those three things um and obviously
other stuff
good so you've got a lot you mentioned
that
you know mental health is is something
top of mind for you
how important is it for you to share
that with with your fans and people who
are just discovering you and being being
that open book
um it's really important you know it's
also very important to learn how to
share it
because i mean i'm at a lot of like
trial and error like it's good to talk
about things but
if you like depending on how you're
talking about it it's either
making it worse you know we're making it
better so
um i've just been trying to take a lot
of lessons
and learn and wait for my time to talk
about it
and uh because it there will be one and
i have a stage
like uh for a big portion of the rest of
my life so
i it's just about learning how to use it
yeah well jane you're really special and
i
i just i really liked this time talking
with you i think you're really
incredible and you're so talented your
music's incredible
i can't wait to see you again thank you
you have a good day all right
you